this might be Joe Rogan's number one
guest ever Duncan Trussell has appeared
on The Joe Rogan Experience a
mind-blowing 57 total times since the
show started back in 2010 but Joe and
Duncan's friendship goes back even
farther than that to when Duncan worked
as a door guy at the comedy store in La
and Rogan would call him to book spots
in the early 2000s Duncan was recently
back on Joe's podcast to celebrate the
show's 2000th episode and he went in
style this time dressed as a furry
Duncan and Joe always give fans
something extra to look forward to by
dressing up in funny versions of
different costumes every time they get
together which is why many people
believe